Darrin asked if you could only mark it
on one social platform which would it be
and why
Darrin I picked this question because
I'm pissed off and I'm pissed off of
people asking this question over and
over again I'm pounding my fist on the
floor or the table over and over this is
a non debate it is Facebook my friends
Facebook's data data data data data let
me say it again as somebody who doesn't
love data who's more EQ than IQ the
overwhelming accuracy of who you are
targeting and the products that they
have created to target those people
including in stream not the right side
of a website so I'm over here I like how
you're staying go back and rework not
the right side of a website but right
down the pipe in the feed targeted
properly and if you're a good enough
marketer and you're putting out content
people care about not an ad and we all
see ads know a piece of content and I
know people are tired of the word
content great call it stuff I don't give
a crap just something people care about
in there when you know stage show Steve
you know Steve likes reddit you know
Steve likes back you know Steve likes
wine you know you know he likes these
things what else do you like Steve she's
doing it great what else needs beer
great so so you know give this man
things of those nuances if you're a
toilet paper or your toothbrush or a toy
company or a cotton cut you know what is
this there's a phone you know technology
company like give this man what he wants
around the genres he cares about
Facebook is by far dark posts that's the
terminology unpublished posts the best
platform to be selling things doing
business getting money for your
charities building awareness about your
cause facebook facebook facebook
facebook
Oh